[Musique]
pitié pour les piétons et pitié pour ces
malheureux sookie le sol se dérobe et
dont le dernier refuge se réduit jusqu'à
menacer de disparaître un conseiller
municipal vient de poser la question ou
pas sont ils et bientôt même passeront
ti
que faire devant un bec de gaz plus
raide que la justice verra-t-on se créer
un syndicat d'entr'aide des piétons
que dire du quartier des halles et de
ses inextricable labyrinthe de cageots
devant un trottoir livré aux
marchandises
le piéton aura-t-il plus d'espoir que
dans ses qualités sportives
devra-t-il dernier rejeton d'une race en
voie d'extinction récupérer en altitude
la portion de trottoir que les voitures
lui ravisse tout heureux au bout du
compte
s'il n'est pas parvenu à se rompre le
cou
et c'est pour des raisons personnelles
ce recours à la gymnastique lui est
interdit et quoi ton qu'il lui sera
possible de faire une tentative de
percée par la chose est interdit et
dangereux
verrons-nous après la fin des trottoirs
la fin des piétons
[Musique]